et c'est le meilleur trimestre en 22 ans
aux états unis qui s'achève en bourse
avec nous pour en parler ce soir le
stratège vincent delisle bonsoir on a
connu vraiment 20 faire de l'île une
première moitié d'année rocambolesque
avec une forte chute et une forte
remontée comment on explique la forte
remontée depuis la fin mars
on va vous l'avez dit c'est une année
qui va passer dans leur entrée dans les
livres d'histoire le ne serait ce que
pour la et l'ampleur de la crise
économique et les soubresauts de la
bourse
le deuxième trimestre a certes été très
très surprenant je vous dirais surtout
par son par l'amplitude de l'habitude de
la dollhouse et ça a suivi un mois de
mars catastrophique donc ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que la
bourse semble avoir décidé les
investisseurs boursiers sam avoir
déterminé que le pire de la récession
est derrière nous et c'est un point qui
est important à mentionner le lilas les
bourses rebondissent et musulmans quand
on passe le pays de la récession pas que
la récession est terminée
alors je pense que ça ajoute un peu le
jobbik et des gens qui sont surpris de
voir les indices boursiers ont rebondi
le fait qu'ils aient eu rebond n'est pas
si surprenant que sur l'amplitude oui
peut-être sur piste alors regardons un
tableau sur le bilan du premier semestre
du 1er janvier au 30 juin 2020 s and p
500 -5% nasdaq + 11 %
tsx -8% à analyser pour nous un peu
l'évolution de ces indices
oui à fait ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le nasdaq et koné 10 à connotation
plus technologique et en territoire
positif
le tsx a plus de ressources plus de
commodité donc affiche des pertes ou
comme des pertes un peu moins important
pour le cnv 500 ce qui ce qui est à
retenir cette année ont eu deux
trimestres est différent à la bourse le
1er trimestre est négatif le deuxième
trimestre est positif mais les gagnants
sont restés les mêmes
alors cette crise là et elle est unique
il ya certains secteurs certaines
industries qui en tirent profit d'autres
qui se
beaucoup alors le nasdaq c'est l'univers
technologique c'est l'univers d'une
innovation regarder ce qu'on fait ce
soir comme entrevue regardez ce que tout
le monde ont depuis le début de cette
crise le beaucoup de technologies alors
ça explique pourquoi les titres de
technologie un indice comme le nasdaq
au mieux fait et il avait mieux fait ou
si c'est un existant dans la dette dans
la débandade du mois de baston qu'il des
gagnants sont restés les mêmes
malgré du trimestre différent et on est
venu effacer essentiellement donc les
pertes qu on a connu les obligations on
va revoir notre tableau et les
obligations plus c'est pour ça oui
alors les obligations les obligations
sont doivent toujours être la portion
une défensive du système l'endimed d'un
portefeuille ça mieux et au deuxième
trimestre pour les obligations parce que
la composante obligations corporatives
se redresser mais les actifs donc
lorsqu'on fait le bilan
la performance des six premiers mois
lorsqu'on regarde la performance de nos
portefeuilles autres en juin on doit
être content d'avoir des obligations où
on doit être content d'avoir des
secteurs qui sont un peu plus défensif
et la nouveauté dans ce cycle aussi
excellé nasdaq ce sont les titres
technologiques
ils sont restés en route le temps tout
au long de l'année et donc le pétrole
moins 35 lors +17 c'est probablement ça
c'est un portrait auquel on pouvait
s'attendre là on pouvait s'attendre
absolument je voudrais que les intrus
dans le tableau lettre u parmi les
gagnants de 2020 c'est le nasdaq ce
secteur technologique parce qu'avec avec
l'ampleur de la récession et surtout
l'ampleur des mesures de stimulus qui
ont été adoptées par les banques
centrales et par les gouvernements
alors ça va amener ça aide
le prix de l'or le secteur aurifère qui
a très bien fait dans l'est dans les
derniers mois alors aurifère secteur de
l'or les obligations et le secteur
technologique sont en haut du pavé le
pétrole et ont rebondi dans les derniers
mois avec avait connu un début d'année
assez ce qu'on regarde de près toujours
ce que vous regardez de près c'est ce
qu'on appelle l' indice de volatilité le
vix
d'abord expliquer d'où c'est quoi le vix
le vix est une mesure de volatilité je
voudrais pour simplifier c'est un peu
c'était une mesure on mesure le moral du
marché à tous les jours à tous les
minutes
en fait sur votre graphique de la ligne
du big c est les bleus est
habituellement il n'y a pas trop
d'inquiétudes sur le marché ligne bleue
qui est base ça indique que les
investisseurs sont somme toute
confortable et on peut voir fin février
soit au mois de mars
l'explosion murray la volatilité qui est
allé en ligne alors si vous regardez
cette ligne cette ligne bleue la parole
est probablement ce que tout le monde
avait pu à partir de la mi mars lorsque
les économies et les ont été confinés
lorsqu'en 2000 québec sur pause et
s'était fait à l'échelle planétaire
alors à ce moment-là fin mars
c'est le moment de panique dans le
marché le seuil émotif avait jamais
atteint des niveaux
le pessimisme aussi extrême parce que
c'était très facile de s'attendre au
pire
et ils vous diraient que ce qui est ce
qui ajoute à ses clients c'est le fait
que c'est une crise qu'on a tous vécu
personnellement le vécu de nos maisons
ont le vécu ce que ce plan familial
alors serait-ce qu'à ajouter au niveau
de stress dans le marché et ce qui s'est
passé dans les derniers mois en avril
mai juin ce qu'explique un marché
boursier qui rebondit c'est que le moral
des investisseurs s'est amélioré on
n'est pas encore revenu des niveaux est
très très confortable mais après la can
et du mois de mars
ça s'est amélioré mais en quelques mots
ce fait fi quoi la leçon qu'il faut
tirer des derniers mois pour les
investisseurs je me suis une leçon qui
est très très importante
on doit avoir lorsqu'on discute avec son
conseiller de plasma ce qu'on regarde
son portefeuille il ya des principes qui
doivent qui doivent tenir on doit avoir
un portefeuille qui raflait sa propre
tolérance au risque et qu'il reflète
aussi n'autorisons placement sûr nous ne
lisons placement de 10 15 20 ans une
telle crise
oui ça va et équitable ne devrait pas
nous faire paniquer dans les
portefeuilles
on doit faire des ajustements
périodiques meilleurs rôles ces
ajustements ne doivent pas être guidé
par les émotions et bane heureusement
le vus à l'extrême cette année le
sentiment de panique qui était très
élevé et donc aux prises et moi si on
gère le portefeuille va avoir un plan de
marche pour pour réagir à postérieur le
bouton panique jamais prêt très loin
merci vincent de lewy attaque les et
merci au revoir